[Música]
sap orilla recibe a los civiles que
lograron salir de la zona adyacente a la
planta siderúrgica de s'hostal el último
bastión de la resistencia ucraniana en
la ciudad de mario coli mientras que un
misil ruso golpeó deza
el partido de izquierda a la francia
insumisa y los ecologistas alcanzaron un
histórico acuerdo de cara a las
elecciones legislativas de junio el
pacto supone la unión de las formaciones
de izquierda más votadas en la primera
vuelta de las pasadas presidenciales
tenemos análisis
en colombia el candidato presidencial de
la izquierda y favorito en los sondeos
gustavo petro denunció un supuesto
atentado contra su vida razón por la que
suspendió parte de sus actos de campaña
en la recta final para las elecciones
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentina torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en ucrania donde
el foco se centra en la evacuación de
personas refugiadas en la planta das
hostal considerada el último bastión de
la resistencia ucraniana en el puerto de
mariupol entretanto rusia volvió a
bombardear la ciudad de odessa al tiempo
que el canciller ruso sérguei lávrov
despertó una polémica al decir que al
igual que el presidente volodymyr
selenski adolf hitler también tenía
orígenes judíos por otra parte los
ministros de energía de la unión europea
discutieron formas de compensar los
posibles cortes de gas de rusia gazprom
de as suspendió los suministros a
polonia y bulgaria la semana pasada y
los funcionarios dicen que cualquier
estado miembro podría ser el próximo el
comisionado de energía del bloque
destacó la importancia de acelerar el
despliegue de las energías renovables
la unión europea' trata de presentar un
frente unido contra rusia se espera que
el bloque proponga un veto gradual al
petróleo ruso pero hungría dice que no
aceptará ninguna medida que ponga en
peligro su suministro de petróleo y gas
la posición contrasta con la de polonia
que quiere sancionar a ambos
no deberíamos apoyar a gazprom o no
deberíamos apoyar la economía rusa no
estamos obligados a seguir el decreto de
putin seguir la ley de putin putin
la reunión de emergencia del lunes tuvo
como objetivo prepararse para una
posible falla en el suministro de gas
ruso ya que la unión europea se niega a
cumplir las exigencias de moscú de
pagarlo en rublos el método de pago
sugerido por rusia consiste en depositar
euros o dólares en una cuenta bancaria
de gazprom que pasaría por el banco
central ruso sancionado y llegaría a una
segunda cuenta en rublos
y pagar en rublos a través del mecanismo
de conversión administrado por las
autoridades públicas rusas y una segunda
cuenta dedicada en gazprombank es una
violación de las sanciones y no puede
aceptarse
la semana pasada gazprom suspendió el
suministro de gas a polonia y bulgaria
después de que se negaran a pagar en
rublos por ahora los países tienen
alternativas polonia recibe gas natural
licuado originalmente de eeuu mientras
que bulgaria recibe gas desde grecia sin
embargo los funcionarios de la unión
europea temen que rusia pueda detener
los suministros a otros estados miembros
para prepararse el bloque tiene tres
prioridades
y mejorar sus planes de contingencia de
abastecimiento recargar las reservas de
gas para la próxima temporada y
diversificar sus fuentes de energía las
reservas de europa se encuentran
actualmente por encima del 32%
cambiamos de tema y vamos a francia el
partido de la francia insumisa liderado
por jean luc mélenchon logró un
histórico acuerdo con el movimiento
ecologista juntos son las dos fuerzas de
izquierda más votadas en la primera
vuelta de las presidenciales de abril el
pacto es clave para las elecciones
legislativas que se llevarán a cabo el
12 de junio y hay expectativa por
acuerdos similares que podrían lograrse
con los partidos socialista y comunista
pues el fin es unir un gran frente de
izquierda que permita lograr un bloque
influyente en el parlamento
previamente conversamos con flojeó en la
fax analista político que nos explicó
cuáles son los principales puntos de
convergencia y de diferencia entre la
francia insumisa y los ecologistas
claro bueno hay que destacar que está
este programa que quieren imponer
entre ellos es un programa que se hizo
bajo las condiciones de los insumisos
entonces son condiciones programáticas
que no fueron negociadas dentro de estas
es la implementación de una nueva
república la sexta la jubilación a los
60 años el sueldo mínimo a 1400 euros la
planificación ecológica la salida de la
energía nuclear salida también de la
ventana de la alianza militar occidental
y harto el balance de la presidencia
socialista de fósforo pero también lo
que es más problemático es la obligación
para los partidos que se alcanzan con
los insumisos de aceptar de desobedecer
a los tratados de la unión europea eso
es un punto clave que
hace surgir divisiones muy importantes
con los otros partidos de izquierda
porque en el derecho internacional
existe una idea de continuidad
lo que implica respeto de los tratados
firmados por gobiernos anteriores no
existe la posibilidad de permanecer
dentro de un tratado aquí la unión
europea respetando solamente una parte
de las reglas y las reglas que les
podría convenir entonces quedan dos
opciones o negociar nuevamente pero es
muy difícil e intento de poner a unión
europea con 27 enmendó miembros osarios
de estos tratados que sería decir de que
francia tendría que salir de la unión
europea y la unión europea es una
propiedad no del centro de la cual se
tiene que respetar las normas y no se
puede elegir en las reglas que uno
quiere y no respetar a otras es muy
difícil lo del tema de la salida de la
otan también es un tema que es muy clave
y muy difícil para los verdes aceptarlos
sobre todo dentro del contexto que
tenemos que es el contexto de la guerra
en ucrania cabe destacar que eso
va dentro del concepto de inmigración de
una política exterior no alineada pero
que podría aparecer como una política
muy pro putin muy pro rusia y también
quiero recordarles que en 2017 esta
política no alineada no está totalmente
alineada porque emerson proponía por
ejemplo integrar la alba que es alianza
con venezuela
en colombia gustavo petro favorito según
los sondeos a las elecciones
presidenciales del 29 de mayo denunció
que había un plan para atentar contra su
vida durante la gira que planeaba para
el miércoles y el jueves en el centro
del país temores que evocan a tiempos
pasados en los que se produjeron otros
magnicidios de candidatos la policía y
el ministerio del interior dicen que no
tenían evidencias de información al
respecto luís muñoz tiene más detalles
una denuncia de amenaza que evoca a
fantasmas del pasado
el candidato de izquierda a la
presidencia gustavo petro suspendió su
gira en el centro de colombia por
razones de seguridad su equipo habría
recibido información de planes para
atentar contra su vida
lamentable que tenga que suspender la
gira del eje cafetero el paso de los
sectores de la corrupción apagar bandas
de sicarios para mi eliminación física
muestra la desesperación política a la
que han llegado
gustavo petro pensaba viajar el 3 y el 4
de mayo al eje cafetero en el centro del
país allí opera una organización
criminal conocida como la cordillera que
estaría detrás de la amenaza y está
señalada de haber acabado con la vida
del estudiante lucas biglia en pereira
durante el paro nacional de 2021 una
conmoción ya conocida para colombia pues
el país tiene un historial de
magnicidios contra candidatos
presidenciales el 9 de abril de 1948
jorge eliécer gaitán fue asesinado en el
centro de bogotá dando lugar a una
cruenta guerra entre liberales y
conservadores en 1989 el liberal luis
carlos galán fue asesinado cuando era
favorito ganar la contienda de 1990
antes de esas elecciones también
murieron el líder de la desmovilizada
guerrilla del m-19 a la que perteneció a
gustavo petro carlos pizarro y el
izquierdista bernardo jaramillo ossa de
la unión patriótica organización contra
la que la jurisdicción especial para la
paz considera que hubo un genocidio
temores de tiempos pasados cuando según
la última encuesta de invamer gustavo
petro aventaja en alrededor de 17 puntos
al candidato de la derecha federico
gutiérrez potencia mundial de la vida y
nos despedimos desde el sur del
continente americano a 100 años del
nacimiento de josé saramago la feria del
libro de buenos aires le rindió homenaje
con una maratón de lectura de sus textos
dramatizada por mujeres se trató de una
selección de las letras del propio autor
realizada por su esposa y traductora
pilar del río el nombre del evento fue
recordando ajuste de bolsos de mujer en
la obra de saramago
este homenaje consiste en
en unos textos de las voces femeninas en
saramago a mí me tocó ensayo sobre la
ceguera y
y entonces hago un fragmento de esto
donde
todos se han vuelto ciegos en este mundo
- la mujer del médico que es un poco el
baboso parte desde la parte lúcida y qué
que va llevando el relato de la novela
así finalizamos esta informativo a
ustedes muchas gracias por su sintonía
[Música]